I am a software engineer at stripe my
name is Lila what is stripe so stripe is
a technology company that is trying to
solve the problem of building and
running an internet business anywhere in
the world using technology and the bread
and butter of our product is the ability
to for online businesses to accept
payments very easily
through extremely developer friendly aps
and we offer a bunch of other tools that
are related to the internet business
space but my work ties in directly to
accepting payments now with that in mind
what exactly is credit card fraud so
let's use a hypothetical example to try
and understand this so let's say you're
a fraudster steals your credit card
information somehow and the most common
cause of this would be a data breach for
example the big target data breach from
about five years ago ton of compromised
credit cards and people can buy these
credit cards for a few bucks somewhere
in the dark web so someone has stolen
your credit card number they buy some
expensive item online for our example
let's say they buy a really expensive
watch like a Rolex online using your
card they then resell this item on some
anonymized marketplace such as
Craigslist they usually sell it for less
than they bought it for but they didn't
actually pay for it so you know it's all
profit a few days later you're looking
at your credit card statement and you're
like I did not buy a Rolex and so at
that point you initiate what is called a
dispute or a charge back with your bank
for this watch it in purchase and you
might be you might have seen you can't
really see this here but there's usually
a dispute charge button if you log in to
your bank account online so why do
stripes merchants these are because our
merchants are the online businesses in
this case the websites I'm the watch why
do they care about fraud because it
wasn't their card card that was stolen
right
so the way things work if I dispute this
charge with my bank let's say I initiate
a dispute with Chase and the bank
decides that yes this transaction truly
was fraudulent and Lula is not on the
hook for this the merchant the watch
seller is actually on the hook for the
cost of that item and the literal cost
of fraud is the value of the stolen item
plus some dispute fees and so you can
imagine that if fraudsters realize that
a certain merchant has very poor
protections in place and decide to
hammer them the merchant can end up
losing a lot of money globally in 2018
fraud losses through credit card fraud
is estimated to be about twenty billion
dollars so this is a huge huge market so
with that in mind there are three major
challenges that we have encountered at
stripe while dealing with credit card
fraud so the first is that it's not
always obvious to everyone what fraud
means the example I just presented with
someone stealing your credit card number
and buying something illegally
that's pretty cut-and-dry as this was
fraud there are some more like gray area
types of fraud one example is
subscriptions fraud where you repeatedly
sign up for a free trial of a service
like blue apron and you know after the
month you get your free meals and then
you just cancel and then you sign up
again using a different account because
you don't want to pay for the actual
service that's called subscription fraud
there are other types of fraud such as
friendly fraud where someone buys an
item and they meant to buy the item but
they just don't recognize what the
statement description means they don't
recognize the merchant name so they say
this is fraud and they're not actually
like ill-intentioned
they just literally are confused about
the fact that they made this purchase so
you can get into conversations with
people where they might have different
ideas for what fraud means and it's you
might not always be on the same
each second no matter how you define
fraud whether or not you include
subscription fraud family fraud all that
kind of stuff the vast majority of
charges are not fraud the bulk of
transactions happening on the Internet
are made by legitimate well-meaning
customers who are genuinely buying that
good or service with their own credit
card
and finally when merchants are victims
at fraud they aren't always experts at
evaluating the business impact of fraud
so what does that mean so when you're
hit with fraud remember you're on the
hook for the cost of this fraud and so a
lot of merchants have strong emotional
reactions to this because they're paying
for these things that were fraudulently
obtained even though they had nothing to
do with the person's credit card number
being stolen and so when you actually
look at how fraud impacts merchants
bottom lines you it's not always obvious
that merchants are considering it the
same way we do we're a knee-jerk
reaction when you're faced with fraud
for the first time it might be I should
just block all charges that's not
probably not the smartest decision for
your business because then you won't
actually do any business but you will
succeed in not having any fraud so it's
always a tricky balance to figure out
exactly what the objective business
impact of fraud is and to try and
separate that from the emotional impact
of fraud so how have these challenges
translated into problems for our machine
learning so it's not always easy to
agree on ground truth for what fraud
means you need to have labels for your
data if you're training a model to
detect fraud and you need to agree on
something some kind of definition for
fraud before you can have labels that
are meaningful most charges are not
fraudulent means that there is massive
class imbalance in your training data
and since most merchants aren't experts
that have a low rating the true impact
of fraud whereas we actually want to
measure how our models are affecting
their fraud situation I
by reducing their fraud we need to have
some sort of production evaluation
techniques to figure out how well our
models are doing so let's dive into each
of these one by one
effective labeling of data so when we
choose labels our model is a binary
classifier we just care about when it
looks at a transaction it needs to tell
us whether that transaction is fraud or
not and tangentially it is also
important for whatever labels we choose
for fraud versus not fraud to be
obtainable via whatever production
evaluation technique we're using because
if you want to be able to evaluate how
well your model is doing in production
you need to be able to see what those
labels are in production it sounds
obvious but it's worth reiterating and
specifically it's stripe we need these
labels for fraud or not fraud to have
the same meaning across all our
merchants if we define fraud in a
certain way for one merchant and in a
different way for another merchant that
doesn't really help us when we want to
evaluate how well we're doing overall
across all our merchants so we need our
labels to conform to these three major
criteria so what could we use as labels
so for all of our models that are trying
to detect whether or not a transaction
is fraud so using my watch example where
a customer files a chargeback with their
bank for a fraudulent transaction that
one is pretty obviously fraud no matter
who the merchant is no matter who the
customer is no matter who the bank is
similarly there's a concept called
issuer fraud records which are
frequently precursors to charge pacts
where the bank or the card network sees
this charge and they realize that
there's something very sketchy about
this and they send stripe and issue a
fraud record that's kind of like a
premonition of fraud and a large
percentage of transactions that receive
these issue of fraud records actually
end up getting disputed as fraud by the
cardholder and so you might have heard
of
TC 40s that's visa specific version of
facial fraud records but Mastercard Amex
they also have their own versions so for
various specific models that are meant
for single merchants if the merchant
tells us that a certain customer is a
known bad customer where they've had
repeated bad interactions with them and
they want to label this customer as
fraudulent we could use that for a model
that is very specific to that merchant
there's a subtle difference here if we
if we're training a model that works
across multiple merchants and this one
merchant tells us that they don't like a
specific customer it isn't fair for us
to bias other merchants labels with this
merchants judgment so this would only
work in the case where the model is very
specific to a specific merchants and
some examples that are not good for any
of our models regardless of whether
they're for one merchant or for many
merchants so if a customer returns a
product where let's say you order some
clothes online the clothes don't fit so
you send them back that might be
annoying for the merchants but that's
not actually fraudulent similarly if a
certain merchant on stripe decides to
just block all charges from some country
because they had a bad experience of
that country or they noticed that they
had an elevated rate of fraud from that
country that doesn't mean that stripe is
suddenly gonna label all charges from
that country as fraud because that's an
unfair judgment that we're imposing on
charges from that country so at the end
of the day for us
labels depend on our target audience
which more directly ties into what I was
saying about how if we want to use
merchants specific judgments that
merchant has to be the target audience
of the model ultimately we're trying to
optimize for the revenue of our
merchants relative to what they'd have
without our models and this means that
we want our models to block charges that
they consider fraudulent in such a way
that merchants are not going to
on the hook for truly fraudulent charges
we specifically for this reason use
labels such as the chargeback being
filed with the bank or the shore a fraud
record because these are actually
correlated with true fraud that impacts
your bottom line
we don't use labels that are correlated
with the perception of fraud which kind
of ties into the emotional aspect of
fraud we could use different labels if
our goal was to maintain emotional
happiness for our merchants but that's
not what we're going after with our
models we want to actually help your
bottom line and so it's always important
to keep that in mind when we choose our
legals second handling class imbalance
so before I dive into class imbalance
specifically I have a couple of examples
to illustrate the relationship between
precision recall and FPR and you can see
most of the slide so let's say we have a
model that scores transactions between
zero and 100 and our current policy here
is if the score is greater than or equal
to 90 we're gonna block the transaction
because we think that means it's fraud
so if we want to calculate precision
recall and FPR on this set of outcomes
what is precision in this case there was
one charge that the model said was fraud
which is transaction six that one was
actually fraud sir precision is 1 out of
1 which is 1
what is Rico there are two fraudulent
transactions in the data set number five
and number six out of those two the
model only correctly detected number six
is fraud so our recall is 1 over 2 which
is 0.5 what is FB are so there were 4
transactions that were not fraudulent 1
2 3 and 4 our model correctly said that
none of those were fraudulent so our FBR
is 0 out of four because we didn't
incorrectly label a good transaction as
fraud answer f PR is 0 which is great
I've taken the same data if we instead
change our models policy to blah
if the score is greater than or equal to
30
all our metric values change so now for
precision our model has said three
transactions or fraud four five and six
only two of those are actually fraud
numbers five and six so now our position
is two-thirds which is not the same as
the one we had in the previous example
recall on the other hand there were two
fraudulent transactions number five and
six the model correctly said that both
of those four falkland so our Rico's two
over two or one point O which is much
better than last time last time was just
point five and FBR now we have four
truly non fraudulent transactions
unfortunately our model mistakenly said
one of those was fraud number four so
our FPR is one over four so just by
changing the threshold at which we are
blocking transactions we've completely
changed the values of these metrics
although the underlying model actually
hasn't changed now with that in mind
let's talk about class imbalance so as I
mentioned a little while ago very few
transactions that we see are actually
fraudulent this is less than 1% so it
means that more than 99% of transactions
are legitimate and made in good faith
however it also turns out that model
performance is better when you train on
a more balanced data set and as proof of
that I can mostly see these the
precision recall curve on the left is
was obtained by training on a very
imbalanced data set and it looks really
bad it kind of dips and it never really
comes up it flattens I have that on
another slide I'll blow it up again and
the one on the right is a more normal
looking precision recall curve and that
one was obtained on a more balanced data
set so why does this happen
so our model produces a score for every
charge between 0 and 100 our policy is
that since our model is a binary
classifier where we Ultima
we need to say block or don't block we
pick a threshold between zero and a
hundred at which we decide to block or
not block and basically the way that
works is you pick your threshold if the
score for that transaction is greater
than or equal to the threshold you block
the charge if it is less than that you
allow it and we picked a threshold in
general to maximize recall while capping
FPR now why does that make sense
our ultimate goal is to maximize revenue
of our merchants and to optimize fraud
blocking for that I couldn't theory
block every single charge and you'd have
a recall of one and you would never
experience fraud but then your FBR would
be off the charts because remember 99%
of transactions are not fraud so I've
just ended up blocking a lot of good
charges simply to have a recall of one
by maximizing recall while capping FBR
I'm maximizing the amount of fraud the
model is blocking for you
but also not hurting good customers by
wrongly blocking their well-intentioned
transactions and so let's say our
validation set has very few fraudulent
charges relative to non fraudulent
charges so the validation set is
extremely imbalanced so given the
definition of F PR which is false
positives were false positives was true
negatives and so false positives is
legitimate transactions that the model
has incorrectly said we're fraud true
negatives are legitimate transactions
that the model correctly said were
legitimate and then block if your
validation set is very imbalanced you
can get a lot of charges classified
wrong you can cost write a lot of good
charges wrong and still have a
relatively low F PR because the true
negatives part of the denominator in f
PR is really really large and what this
ends up resulting in is you pick a very
low threshold but on a zero to 100 scale
and this results in very high Rico
very low precision and you can sort of
see what's happening in this precision
recall curve which is the same one that
was cut off where very quickly recall is
doing well but precision has just fallen
off a cliff so this all sounds good but
there's a slight pitch when we train our
model on a balanced data set we end up
with balanced validation data and we're
picking our optimal block threshold such
that we optimize performance on the
validation data however we ultimately
run our model in production production
is not balanced data production still
has only 1% fraud in it there's no way
for me to morph production data such
that it is balanced because that's not
how the real world works unfortunately
so ultimately when you are trying to
figure out how to set up class balance
for training it's not always obvious
that the class balance that works best
in validation will be the same one that
works best against imbalance production
data what is what we've generally found
to be true is that imbalanced training
data does not do the best on either
validation or evaluation data but the
class balance you use the one that is
optimal on production data might not be
the most optimal one on validation data
so it's important to make sure you're
looking at both so what did we end up
doing so we decided to run a set of
experiments to determine the optimal
target rate for fraudulent transactions
in our training data set what do I mean
by target rate so I we basically tried
out different percentages where we said
that we wanted our training data set to
be X percent fraud and 100 minus X
percent not fraud and we tried out
different values of X plotted different
ROC curves it's a little bit blurry but
one of them ended up working out the
best the way we make this happen is we
keep all the fraudulent transactions we
can get our hands
because fraud is really rare and we
downsample the non fraudulent
transactions as needed such that we can
obtain that target rate for fraud in the
training data set so to use some
concrete numbers to explain this we
let's say we have a data set which has a
thousand charges out of those ten of
them our fraud 990 are not fraud and
let's say in our experiments we
determined that the best target rate in
training data is 10% means that 10% of
your training data has to be fraudulent
charges so in this example what we would
do is we will keep all those 10
fraudulent charges in the training data
and we would only keep 90 of the non
fraudulent charges in the training data
we would literally discard 900 of the
non fraudulent charges and this seems
counterintuitive but I trust experiments
and experiments prove that this worked
best so the final lesson and takeaway
for us is around having a good
production evaluation technique for your
model so I'll get to what the
counterfactual part of this means in a
little bit but let's talk about why you
need a production model evaluation
technique so if you look at this diagram
I'm not sure how clear it is for you
guys
but if you look at the universe of all
charges our model sees true positives in
the case of our model our fraudulent
transactions that the model has
correctly identified as fraudulent and
ends up blocking false positives are
legitimate transactions that the model
wrongly thought were fraudulent and
therefore wrongly blocked this is
straightforward but if your model blocks
a charge in production because it thinks
this charge is fraudulent how do you
know that the model got it right so the
way we determine if a charge is
fraudulent or not is the charge goes
and some days or weeks later we see this
chargeback being initiated via the
customer whose card was used through
their bank's website but if we think a
charge is fraudulent and we block it
because we think it's fraudulent we
haven't left the charge go through to
see if there's going to be discharged
back file by the customer so how do we
actually know if we were correct in
determining that this was fraud
similarly if we blocked something
because we thought it was fraud how do I
know we got it wrong
how do we know that this wasn't actually
going to end up being fraud we're
basically biasing the outcomes of our
charges using our model so we need some
way to estimate unbiased data for true
and false positives because we need to
have these numbers to calculate
precision and recall in production we
can very easily calculate these numbers
on validation data because that is
historical data but if I want to
actually figure out how well my model is
doing in production I need some way to
estimate true and false positives in
production so counterfactual evaluation
is the solution here and what that means
is that it's a technique that helps us
measure what would have happened to a
transaction if our machine learning
model had not intervened and blocked it
so it's how we're gonna estimate what
would have happened in the absence of
the model and there are two primary
motivators here the first is we need to
estimate true and false positives to
figure out how well our model is doing
in production because you need to have
an estimate of true and false positives
to calculate precision recall FBR
whatever your favorite metrics are the
second reason which might not be as
intuitive is that this is the same way
we generate unbiased training data why
is that true
so our model in production is blocking
and allowing transactions we
can ultimately only train on the
transactions that we have labels of
fraud and not fraud for and this means
we can only train on transactions that
the model has allowed to go through and
hit the car network because those are
the only ones we can observe the true
outcomes of for the ones that the model
has blocked we have no idea what's
happening to those because the model
blocked them and hasn't let them go
through the network to see what
ultimately happens but our model is
still blocking transactions that things
are fraud right so the model is blocking
most things that it thinks are fraud and
out of all the transactions that the
model that's through the bulk are not
fraud because there's a reason why the
model and block them so the only fraud
that we end up seeing with true labels
is the fraud that the model could not
catch and therefore let through so this
means that the fraudulent transactions
that we have true outcomes for are the
hardest fraud because the model could
not catch them that's why it let them
through and what ends up happening is
that if you literally just use these
transactions that you had labels for
because the model let them through over
time the model forgets what easy fraud
looks like because you keep training it
on only the really hard fraud that it
let through because it can catch and
over time it just doesn't know what
normal or easy fraud looks like and and
some not being able to catch it and so
we need some way to obtain labels for
some of the more easy fraud that the
model would have blocked so that we can
use these in training to keep our model
more effective and this is a real
problem
so the ROC curve on the left was when we
first strained the model it was doing
great and then the kernel on the right
which is a lot worse was after the model
forgot what easy fraud look like because
we just kept training it on the really
really hard fraud so how do we set up
our counterfactual evaluation framework
to solve these two issues
the first attempts that we tried we took
a small percentage of the transactions
that the model would have blocked and we
reversed the decision to block them and
actually let them go through instead and
we used a propensity function to
determine the probability of allowing
that transaction so if you look at this
chart here we have this model that
hypothetically blocks if the score was
greater than 60 so for all transactions
is a score of less than 60 probability
of allowing is 1 because the model is
not going to block anything that has a
score of less than 60 for scores between
sixty and a hundred there's a decreasing
probability of letting that transaction
through and as you might have observed
the probability of allowing it is
inversely proportional to how high the
score is the goal was you don't want to
let through as many of the most
fraudulent transactions which would
ideally have a score closer to 100
compared to the least fraudulent
transactions and this way we let through
some amount of the more normal fraud
which is between 60 and 100 to obtain
through outcomes on those transactions
so how do we evaluate model performance
using these we would only look at
transactions that were allowed by the
model because those are the only
transactions for which we have outcomes
but now in addition to all the
transactions that the model was
previously letting through which are
legitimate transactions and the really
hard fraud it couldn't catch we're also
letting through some of the more normal
fraud that the model is correctly
detecting as fraud but we are
consciously reversing the decision to
block them we would then operate each
transaction that the model allowed by 1
over PLL so if the model was going to
allow this transaction all along the
score was less than 60 this weight was
going to be one but if the model is
gonna block this transaction and it had
a point 1 probability of being reversed
now we are allowing if we end up
allowing that transaction it gets up
weighted
by one over point one which is ten and
we would use these weights in both
training and evaluation and as an
example as anyone who's used
scikit-learn is probably aware you can
use sample weights really easy when
calculating precision and recall and the
sample weight equals weight is these
weights that were won over PLL and just
as an example of how this looked so
let's say our model had a default policy
to block if the score is greater than or
equal to 80 the two transactions that
the model would have blocked number
three and four had scores of 80 and 90
and given the P allows for them they
have weights of five and ten so of those
two the more we ended up allowing both
of those to see the true outcomes the
model would have only blocked
transaction four sorry out of the two
transactions the only one that the model
would have blocked that ended up
actually being fraud was transaction for
transaction three would have been
blocked but the true outcome was that it
was not fraud so our precision is 10
over 10 plus 5 which is 10 or 15 or 2/3
for recall transactions 2 and 4 are
truly fraud when we obtain their
outcomes out of those we would have only
blocked transaction for transaction 2
was allowed so the recall is 10 over 10
plus 1 which is 10 over 11 or about 0.9
1 so this all sounds great but we found
some issues here these weights the 1
over P allow had a lot of variance and
noise and this ended up having results
there's an air causing variance when we
were estimating precision and recall
using these weights a single transaction
with a high weight that we got wrong
could shift the estimates significantly
so what does this mean let's say we had
10 fraudulent transactions
and one of those was a transaction that
we reversed and it had a P allow of
point one I said let's say point zero
one it was like a really really Friday
transaction in the eyes at the model and
we reverse it with the probability of
point zero one so now it has a weight of
a hundred and if we caught this
transaction wrong the weight of a
hundred far supersedes the weights of
the other nine transactions which are
all significantly lower and that would
just end up really shifting the values
of precision and recall secondly the
calculation of P allow was not as
straightforward as it sounds when we
design that propensity function with the
inverse probability of reversal we the
function assume that all events it was
fed to calculate P ll4 were independent
events what does that mean for us does
this mean the events should be user
sessions where each user session is an
independent event should it be each
individual transaction how do you deal
with people who are repeatedly retrying
the same transaction where let's say the
first time they try to make the
transaction but there's a typo and how
they entered their name or their CVC and
then the next time they try again and
they get it right like should both those
have the same probability because the
way the function works it
deterministically generates the same PLL
for this for every event but you need to
actually have confidence in the
independence of your events for this to
work and we didn't really have
confidence at the end of the day so we
tried something new and this is what we
do today for a small percentage of
transactions we score the transaction
using our model the model produces the 0
to 100 score as always and no matter
what the score is if you're in that X
percent the transaction is 11 so this
ends up meaning that all transactions
that the model would have blocked so
all transactions between sixty and a
hundred four scores all now have a
uniform probability of reversal it also
means that all transactions regardless
of score have a uniform probability of
reversal but it doesn't really matter if
you were gonna let through that
transaction anyway and if you look at
the propensity function now it's much
simpler if you if we were not gonna
block the charge we're still not gonna
block the charge and any charge that we
were gonna block I have used a
hypothetical 0.1 PLL for all
transactions we were gonna block and all
transaction in this X percent that we
call our whole back group get uniformly
operated instead of having this variance
in the up waiting because P allow is now
constant why does this work better for
us we now are not dealing with any sort
of variance in our weights because we
have a uniform PLL we have uniform
weights and this means that we aren't
having a single highway transaction bias
the estimators for our metrics and we
aren't overestimating or underestimated
metrics because of the lack of various
the X percent the whole back group is a
uniform sub sample of all transactions
and so we consider this group to
uniformly represent our entire world and
we can calculate true precision and
recall since its uniform sub sample
ultimately the reason why we like this
method a lot more is that we got rid of
variance in our estimator function and
as a result of that we have much more
confidence in the actual estimates the
function is producing and since we also
use these weights and training the good
news is that our precision recall curve
ended up looking mostly the same
so just switching to this method of
uniform weights did not actually have a
negative impact on training either so
what are our takeaways here first is
that when you're labeling your data for
your model to train on and evaluate on
the appropriate label to use depends on
what problem you're trying to optimize
for which in our case was
revenue maximization if we wanted to
optimize for emotional happiness would
probably need different labels also the
labels you used depend on the context of
scope of the problem where if you want
to apply specific judgments to specific
groups of parents you need to make sure
that your model is very tailored to that
group secondly aiming for a constant
target rate in the training data for the
positive class which is fraud in our
case rather than a fixed down sampling
rate for the negative class which is the
non fraud results in the best long-term
class balance and model performance for
us the problem with fixing the sub
sampling rate for the negative class is
that if your data is growing over time
in volume then it will end up varying
the target rate for the positive class
and at least for us we found that this
was an issue because the number of
transactions we were processing was
growing year over year so fixing the
target rate worked out much better than
fixing the down sampling rate thirdly
you need a counterfactual evaluation
strategy that works so that you can
evaluate how well your model is doing in
production and that is also
statistically sound so that you actually
trust the estimates that it is producing
for you thank you for listening and I
would love to answer any questions
[Applause]
thanks for the great talk
so you mentioned how you sometimes let
fraud fraudulent transactions go through
even though your model thinks it's fraud
and so basically I mean this is really
great for the long term because it
allows you to build great models in a
long term but it could potentially hurt
a merchant in the short term so and and
your publicly saying that you're doing
this so do you think like there might be
a case where a merchant accuses you of
saying hey like why did you let this
rajala I mean they probably don't know
like what's going on with your model but
do you think you could ever be like
accused for you know for not preventing
harm that could have been prevented so
we're actually super open about the fact
that we do this it's in our Terms of
Service it's in our documentation and
we're very explicit that doing this
results in optimal model performance for
that forgetting fraud reason we like I
used 10% as a hypothetical number we're
not letting through 10% of things we
were blocked we've found that the number
we've basically optimized for the
minimum number we can let through
without actually having any sort of
meaningful impact but there's also a
trade-off right where I can make you a
much worse model without doing this and
people are pretty receptive to that
where they understand the trade-offs
between the two but yeah we're not
trying to be shady about it's like we're
pretty explicit about why we do it and
if there were a way to have our models
do really well without doing it we
totally do that
but that way did not work so this is
where we're at yeah question
q DPRs and the right to be forgotten how
do we do handle that so this does not
really involve any PII so it doesn't
touch GDP are like GDP are for us
involves like personal information
personally identifiable information on
each transaction these functions don't
deal with any personally identifiable
information like when we're choosing if
we're not using any information about
the consumer to choose whether what the
P allow for that event is now like the
function does not actually care about
the contents of the data
I actually didn't understand on the talk
like venue trainer when you basically
subsample the training set and then try
to build a model on the validation set
like when you test the validation set it
still basically performs good but in
production it should be it's actually
the unbalanced data so did you ever try
one class classification methods what do
you mean by one class this kind of
problem is very common in literature in
computer science literature which is
called one class classification actually
so because it's totally an unbalanced
set you're trying to figure out what are
the fraudsters and you don't know among
the population which is the fraud
population but we actually know which
ones are fraud because we only train on
transactions we have the labels for oh I
get that but did among the all the
transactions coming you don't know which
one is fraud in production in production
right so that is what is called the one
class classification like mostly they
use support vector machines and that
means one of the techniques which of the
used I'm not sure I understand what this
I'm saying is that you basically do a
binary classification basically so which
are other techniques you applied in that
in binary classification yeah basically
the action models which you tried like
what is the model we use yeah we use
gradient booster trees okay okay
okay call it okay
hi so you're you train tomorrow is apply
training or light training and the
follow-up question is how often do you
update your models so the first question
do we do offline or online we do offline
and the second is we are constantly
retraining every few days yeah thanks
for this talk it was eye-opening for me
I loved some of your slang the word
fraud is like my new favorite word and I
want to know some other stripe slang
give me some other stuff I think I just
made up fraud II I don't think I've like
gotten it to catch on we don't have a
lot of other fraud slang we have a weird
internal language but that's
unfortunately not at the level of fraud
II yeah I had one quick one question as
well you say you're holding out a
certain percentage I super very low
number right how do you know that that's
not itself biased you just do it
randomly or how do you check pick the
sample yeah we have we have a
randomization function based on our
definition of independent event and so
we do a random X percent of that event
in relation to the model freshness I was
curious like if you guys ran a model
historically that performed really well
have you tried using the data set that
you trained on and like push that
forward into like the new data set that
you would train on like a month or so
later it's like is our training window
sort of sliding forward essentially like
you trained a good model it performed
really well so it's like you kind of can
assume that the fraud events that
happened in that training set were good
uh-huh could you not like also just
maintain that data set add it into like
the new one that you train the model on
a month later to have it like receive
that same stuff so that sort of ties in
to like the optimal length of the
training when doing the amount of data
you feed it and
I can give you a whole or talk about
that but ultimately what we realized is
the nature of fraud changes very quickly
and who the victims of fraud are changed
quickly
so using stale data is not always the
right move we have time for two more
questions I think so I'm aware of card
issuers having their own models for
detecting fraud as well does that happen
before or after your process and
follow-up how does that affect your
model and your data how you train and
how you evaluate your results so that
happens after us where if we so first
when we see a transaction it goes
through stripe and we'll apply our model
on it if our model does not block it it
then goes to the network and that's
where the card issuers model would run
and what this means is if we let through
a transaction and then the issuer
decides to block it then again we can't
use that in trading for the same reason
that we don't actually get to see the
labels and yeah but you know where the
issuer probably has a good reason for
blocking it as well and they're
completely independent where we can't
influence what they do so we're just we
just happen to be upstream of it
so we've noticed that fraudsters also
forget what their old tactics were so
you put up a net you catch a bunch of
tuna all the tuna leaves you can't just
clean with dolphins you take the net
down tuna come back
so when you have these these holdout
populations do you find oddities like
that where only the good users that keep
running into the wall are still hitting
those blocks all the frost does figure
out I get blocked every time so they go
to greener pastures and then does that
iterate back and forth because we've
noticed like put the wall up the
fraudsters go away take it down the
Fosters figures back up we can put it up
so we can almost recycle our rules be
like looks like a seasonal thing they
forget to debussy it anything like that
as well not it as nice a pattern as
you're describing but we generally try
to have
chores that try and have memory where
it's like your training data isn't
necessarily looking at really old
transactions but if you have features
that incorporate history into their
values we found that that has helped I
don't know if that specifically answers
what you're asking for but I'm happy to
chat more yeah okay we're a little short
of time so if you have additional
questions you could ask Lita please meet
with her we have a lightning talk
starting in ten minutes
I think it's downstairs in the ballroom
let's please give Lila a hand for her
excellent talk
[Applause]